[Music]
foreign
telescopes are time machines of A Sort
and that's by virtue of the fact that
light as fast as it travels and it is
the fastest propagating
um entity that we know about in all of
science it travels about this far about
one foot every nanosecond detection of
an unidentified radio Source from deep
space can neither be confirmed nor
denied whatever it is it ain't local uh
so if you convert you know nanoseconds
to Miles and you convert uh uh you know
a feet to miles and nanoseconds to
seconds it travels about 186 000 miles
per second which is pretty darn fast but
it's not infinite so therefore whenever
you're looking at something you're not
seeing it as it is right now you're
seeing it as it was sometime in the past
and the farther away something is the
longer the light travel to reach your
eyes or to reach our telescopes and
telescopes are just eyes of a different
sort there might be sensitive to
microwaves in the case of the telescope
scope that I build radio waves gamma
rays but just like your eyeballs your
eyeballs are too refracting telescopes
they have lenses they have detectors and
so when we look at the Sun
and then I'm not advocating as a
professional astronomer never look at
the sun with your remaining good eye but
when you look at the sun you're seeing
it as it was and that period in which it
was was eight minutes ago because it's
93 million miles away and if you convert
feet per nanosecond or miles per second
or miles per hour you get it takes about
eight minutes for light to travel from
the Sun that means that Jordan the sun
could disappear and we wouldn't see it
and we wouldn't know about it really for
at least eight minutes and maybe even
longer so all telescopes are time
machines even the telescopes embedded in
our skulls